he had a much bigger beard back then
actually and he has trimmed it up for us
that's all way to say about him now it's
a lot more accepting I try to keep it
short of speakers so I want to introduce
to you the very first time speaking to
our community finally Hugo so judge what
I've been coming here for this made up
for five years which is longer than I've
lived in New York City for what that's
worth
well I live in Connecticut I'd come down
and get the metro-north chicken made up
and I was actually this made up among
other things including jobs conference
that really inspired me to get involved
in the science community in the city and
led essentially to me having a job I
have currently a data camp and actually
on the podcast earlier this year to talk
about community building in data science
we'll see a bit of that this evening but
the role in places like this to defrost
these types of conversations I'm really
really grateful for I'm also very
grateful to everyone to signify than us
the same thing both are all often and
Jeff way back who initially would thank
you all this evening I was just saying
to Jeff and I find it hard enough to
actually go to work in December let
alone go out in the evening to to
meetups so it's really cool to see see
so many i interested and a few sleeping
faces of the back so this tag
essentially is about web data scientists
really do what the space looks like
according to 50 data scientists who I
had under podcast
data framed this year the great thing
about this talk is that I get to stay 50
other people's opinions and not put
myself on the line which is incredibly
exciting thing to to do so I'll just
tell you give you a slight rundown on
Who I am so I look at data camp can you
put me on if you've heard of dead camp
yeah that's clear data fighting the
podcast okay great
so I was my undergrad was in science and
humanities with a double math major my
PhD in pure math and I choked that eight
people could read my thesis if three
people could understand it so actually I
wanted to apply math research in cell
biology at Yale University where I did
my postdoc and the Max Planck Institute
for cell biology and genetics in Dresden
and then I moved to data camp and I
started off building out there there
Python curriculum and now I've moved to
the marketing team or do a bunch of
things including posting data file
podcasts which is a lot of fun to host
and to speak with other people I I get
to today is data science though zoom in
and check out the nitty gritty of data
science and then discuss what the future
of data science looks like say a first
one to discuss data Sciences as hot and
I want to think about that is Ghana has
a model of technological innovation
called their hype cycle where we see we
have time on on the x-axis and societal
expectations on the y-axis where we have
some sort of trigger of innovation what
is referred to as the
peak of inflated expectations when the
trough of disillusionment I just love
saying these names essentially and the
slope of enlightenment than the plateau
of productivity and so I'm sure you
guess the basic idea here is at the
start and then you start to see okay I'm
clearly not going to answer answer this
because we get a few hints is how to
think about it so let's see what where
big data is in the hype cycle which we
know predated either term bandied around
a lot before data science was so is
beauty trends okay I'm using the number
of searches as a proxy for expectations
of society okay so that's an assumption
making here expectations and then it
starts to starts to go down
okay so if we accept transitive Bella
proxy we can refer this is their
expectations now if I put this with data
science you can see that data science in
terms of Google Trends once you you know
average other noise hasn't paid yet so
once again if we accept the data hype
cycle is a valid model of technological
innovation and the returns is about
Seifer expectations we've got the bet
fair way to go yet we kind of look into
these types of ideas as we as we proceed
this evening that's nothing about data
scientists do and I posit that data
scientists do three things
today's data scientists logistic
regression so let's not go into each of
these in a bit more detail so I which is
absurd and clearly clearly not true of
data science you see all types of crazy
stuff okay so this one I'm gonna zoom in
on this one here this one has Joe
Conway's data scientist as in which is a
Venn diagram itself as an intersection
in a Venn diagram okay so it's clear
that we have an obsession and of course
analysts in there so let's just think
about you know Jews original Venn
diagram which you which we discussed
when he appeared on the podcast earlier
earlier this year and he made it very
clear that it was never meant to be
interpreted as a data scientist Venn
diagram it's intended to be a data
science Venn diagram okay that's how he
thinks about building data science teams
now at alluvium essentially is that you
don't want a unicorn that has a few
series math and stats knowledge and
substantive expertise you build a team
we can get any of these bases covered
and have good communication flow in the
in the middle and you'll see a bit more
about kind of these approaches to
building data science teams
this talk say let's think about what
have impressed us enjoying in this field
so in terms of techniques courage
trajectory and even job titles data
Sciences is ill-defined one company's
data analysts move somewhere else does
exactly the same job they coded data
scientist and vice versa a license on
the podcast in Episode one I said to her
what what challenges whatever these
challenges today and she said do you
think that imprecise ethics no stands
the practice and a lack of consistent
vocabulary I'm not enough challenges for
us today and I agreed with her I think
and we can say that brand enroll in an
article imposter syndrome on Facebook
made it clear that you know to him
anyone who works with data in order to
answer questions it can be considered a
data scientist whether I have that title
or not an answer business questions he
would consider you to be a data
scientist so he see that it's defined in
all of these ways about imposter
syndrome so at the Jupiter colony in New
York City last year Fernando Perez
co-founder collator project Jupiter said
that he still has imposter syndrome and
that is very real
I'll just leave that someone has says
it's real and and he still has a best
initiative we shall keep in mind in this
discipline so in terms of logistics
regression why do people love I'm in
this seriously people love new gistic
regression if you've listened to the
podcast you probably heard me ask a
bunch of guests what's one of your
favorite data science techniques or
methodologies and the amount of times
the answer is logistic regression I
found I found Starling but the reason
it's the case is that it's a simple
model
you can't
about it and it's interpretable you can
say what features have effects and why
essentially it might not perform as well
as some as your some of your sexy items
such as extreme based or CNN but the
optimizing purely for accuracy of your
mole how well it performs is that the
metric optimizing for we wanna have
conversations so about it as well
this is incredibly later when thinking
about you know bidding machine learning
models in health diagnosis for example
or you know making prescriptions or and
anything along those lines of mine art
plays better role in online advertising
but it's incredibly important to think
about optimizing for with respect to
your actual question what is your actual
question that we tell you what
optimizing for and then if you actually
want something like like logistic
regression okay and these are two people
who clearly polish and who's here now
pretty sure she's here so in Crisfield
in ski int among many others so
scientists think the first thing that I
think in this room she moves a really
bad at statistics so I wanna pose a
thought experiment which maybe this room
will get get straightaway I've done it
in several several rooms and so please
have food experiment police have
breathalyzers that the five percent
false positive right so that means if
someone's not drunk will say they're
drunk five percent of the time zero
percent false negative right so if they
are drunk it will say they're drunk okay
so I also tell you in our society one in
a thousand drivers of driving drunk okay
now the police stop a driver at random
and the test is positive so the question
for you is what
probability that the driver is actually
drunk so if you know the answer I'd
appreciate if you didn't shout it out
but does anybody have an intuition I
just want to get some ideas of what what
the probability could could be about 50%
okay great so the actual answer on the
actual answer well just sick the actual
answer is slightly less than than 2%
okay now the mistake that people
generally make and they're you know
they're little studies on this is that
they're getting a false positive right
and be like oh it probably has a 95
percent chance of actually being being
drunk in that case whatever tend to
forget is that the base rate of drivers
thing junk is so low that the chance of
getting one is actually pretty low and
you play that out by actually doing a
CLA ssin in our heads okay so actually
things like that so do this a thousand
imagine we do this a thousand times so
because one in a thousand a drunk on
average 999 people will not be drunk but
due to the false positive rate of five
percent around fifty a bit less around
fifty will test positive okay now one
person will be drunk and because there's
a zero percent false negative right they
also test positive so then we've got 51
people who test positive and only one of
them is actually drunk so one out of 51
are actually drunk so and that's less
than two percent of the positive test
results being being true positives okay
most people who don't have a statistic
Grandal think it's over 80% a lot think
it's over 90% and a substantial portion
think it's 95% and this is known as the
base rate fallacy because people forget
about the original one in one and a
thousand and it's a data scientist job
to think like this and to correct these
heuristics and biases within their
organizations and in society okay in
society Helen Downey and Andrew governor
on the podcast of different points
having conversations around expressing
uncertainty and thinking and talking
probabilistically and so on has an
incredible blog post could what's a cold
it's coasters
it's good why why are we surprised about
Trump winning in 2016 and ayaats that
5:30 I got Clinton a 71 percent chance
of winning a trumpet twenty eight
percent chance of winning and so that
means that troubling according to this
model was actually more likely than
flipping two coins and getting two heads
okay which has a 25% chance which you
wouldn't be that surprised if you flip
two coins about two heads right that's
where so that various post is predicted
that Clinton would win with
probabilities ranging from seventy to
ninety five percent and it was common to
speak of these predictions as are
everyone agreed that Clinton would win
and
different levels of certainty the state
that makes is interpreting these as
deterministic models not probabilistic
models okay so even if an event is only
ten percent likely that's like 33 coins
of getting all heads which once again we
wouldn't find all that surprising my
understanding is that these are the
patient's that she would win not that
she would get the popular vote the 538
model was the prediction that she would
win not the popular vote so as well or
very close exactly say pollsters make
corrections which are actually going to
show you now oh no before that yeah that
was my response to all of this anyway
it's their mi team nightmare machine
which uses deep learning to create
horrible images from those fractions
ratios in instead of percentages which
research seems to suggest that we're
actually better at interpreting 7901 in
five as opposed to 20% and they even
went so far as to say they're one in
seven happens over time one on seven
days of the week is a Thursday
none of us woke up this morning
screaming oh my gosh
can't believe it's a Thursday and nobody
really should be out surprising
Democrats when the Senate next week or
Republicans keep the house so having
this conversation publicly about
managing expectations around what
statistics and probability actually
named the better scientists role in the
emergence of modern modern data science
and a lot of data scientific techniques
of course predate tech specs but what
we've really seen is a lot of the tools
and techniques employed today developed
in tech as well in black in terms of the
tech stack essentially data science
emerge an experience that both Twitter
and you know the first step for a tech
company is to lay a solid data
foundation that you can then use to
perform greatest analytics later on
after that when you're trying to achieve
sustainable growth to use online
experimentation and that's exactly what
Robert did a Twitter for a long time and
then he moved to actually in order to do
the next step which is to build machine
learning pipelines and personalized data
products in order to make better
business decisions so these are kind of
like the three the Prufrock three
problem Trident anyway of data science
in in tech until the machine learning in
tech if you're really interested in this
and I want you to check out Weber
Chang's post on on medium where he talks
about all the steps involved in
determining customer
everything from feature engineering to
model training to model selection
emotive validation to production ization
and one of the things that you know a
lot of aspiring data scientists I think
need to know is that this is what
machinery and production looks like it's
not importing sales phase and posting Yi
results and and getting a result on the
labor board there are a lot of different
things at play here and that isn't to
say that online competitions haven't
opened up a world of machine learning to
to hundreds of thousands of people but
there is the last thing when discussing
what that looks like in tech I think is
science I'm constantly working on that
because come to me and say hey I want to
get data science in my business how do i
how do I like do and are you sending
here until we through the fact that Y is
at the top of a very serious hierarchy
of hierarchy of mains and you need to
lay everything else down before the fact
okay so before even
in any of this stuff up here need to you
know collection data you need to you
know instrumentation logging census
external data user-generated content all
of these things and then you need to get
them into a place which you can read
from essentially ETL infrastructure
databases data Lakes structure and
unstructured data storage only then can
you even start doing some basic cleaning
preparation anomaly detection and after
that of course you start doing analytics
like this is these two sections and
probably here is well you know group
eyes start happening right so we've got
a lot before you can even like color
group by method in pandas the sexiest
stuff I'd be testing experimentation
Silom ml and then only after all of that
can you start in exploring and exploding
so the last aspect of data science that
a high-level I'd like to discuss is how
data science can actually influence the
decision function in an organization
because you can do some of the best data
science and have the best motors in the
world but if you can't use those to
effect change and a long term the
decision makers on as data literate
those the data scientists tried so how
do we actually go about this so the
first thing is to really realize that
your data science work is one of several
inputs into the decision-making process
okay and when I have been a tape of
becoming a data scientist and here
attenders fame on the podcast she
expressed quite nicely that data
scientists with in alms their job
essentially is to take a business
question and in the end you want to get
to a business answer but the data
scientist does is factors it through
turns a business question into a data
question uses that
the data answer and then turns it back
into a business answer and a lot of the
stakeholders might not need to
understand all of this stuff that
happens in the middle and you need to be
able to speak their language on both
sides of all of your work data science
and the communication I don't know what
that day is doing there of course is how
important communication skills and
what's now being called better
translation which is this translation
from data question to business question
and vice versa
of course how include these things are
and Jacqueline Louis who's a dead
Assunta consultant and later in the
Seattle area does a lot of work with
that these days I asked asked her which
skill is more important for data
scientists the ability to use models or
the ability to make PowerPoint slides
and if you want the answer to that you
should check out the episode with
Jacqueline but at that point was called
Jonathan's so check out don't look for
the episode with Jonathan Norris another
question as a data scientist Wendy
scheduled meetings with decision-makers
if you're the person who manages you or
is able to make decisions you know
they're not a morning person and these
are really kind of basic questions you
need to answer around how to affect
change within within your old one way to
think about this when to schedule
meetings right so if you've got problems
with this figure we'll get there in a
second but this is in court proportion
of favorable decisions as a function of
time over a day okay so this was a very
famous paper in 2011 in PNAS where we
saw a favorable decision
down and down and down until lunchtime
and then off to lunch spiked and went
down and down and down often until you
get some more glucose then down down and
down and down okay so think about when
to schedule meetings change based on
your data science work is incredibly
important now is that there was a
follow-up paper to this which started
that with an eighth session on
represented prisoners usually go lost
and are less likely to be granted parole
than prisoners with attorneys so there
is I've just stated may not actually be
true I think the point remains at the
point of studying this which we'll get
to a time and time again is what I just
told you about lot like as you get close
to lunch people get hungry you need more
glucose over that oh yeah and that says
that and this is something we need to be
aware of is that cognitive biases and
this in particular the narrative fallacy
that that formed a very nice-nice story
made us entertain it data scientists in
organizations
okay so I've discussed this with several
people Bev Levinson on the podcast cuz
he calls a cop whose chief data
scientist that Google Cloud whether
Chang as well Emily Robinson I think and
and Jacqueline olace so there are many
ways to think about this and that's
depends on what type of organization
you're in as well but is a center of
excellence where you have a dedicated
data science team that then as there
does their work and then suspense the
results in
around after the fact never better we're
data scientists even better in every
time so you have one on the growth team
or one on each product or all of these
different types of types of things now
there are pros and cons to each of these
I urge you to check out in particular
the conversation Robert Chang about this
but you can imagine that in an embedded
model you have a data scientist on each
team reporting to someone who may not be
actually understand the problems they're
facing the center of excellence and the
data science work is done in a space of
its own the ability to affect change in
other parts of the organization may may
suffer as well so there are traders here
and essentially that's why a lot of
people are interested in the hybrid
model where you have data scientists in
Boden teams yet there's a reporting
structure that brings them back to their
to the data team as a whole of a and B
is a great example data camp is a great
example
okay there's a final model which is the
data scientist is what Cassie Kaza
covered but guru close decision
intelligence operative and the episode
to see what she means by that and from
Cassie which is inspiration is cheap but
we get is expensive and if you're not
willing to pay up don't expect that
there's some magic formula that's going
to give it to you okay so now data
scientists do in terms of being Venn
diagrams etcetera so this thing that
what they actually do okay so today's
data scientists I know there's another
joke okay so
where my favorite Twitter handles was
prescient enough in 2013 to say in data
science 80% of time spent prepared data
20% of times spent complain about need
for prepare data and I think that stands
true to this this very day you spend so
much time in data collection they're
claiming data wrangling building
dashboards and reports are data
visualization are building models and
the models whether they're statistical
inference medals or machine learning
models that are scientists medals and
they also as I keep stressing time and
time again communicate results to two
stakeholders right there and then
business decisions actually made this
will change things develops teapot which
is an automated machine learning package
for the parson automated machine
learning he started that we shouldn't
think of ml2 as there's more like data
science assistants rather than
replacements for for data scientists and
that's something I agree with a great
deal and in terms of being assistance
well that can mean is that a lot of the
bullet points I showed you on the
previous slide may to simply disappear
whether it be you know data cleaning and
wrangling once we get a lot of this
automated building dashboards as well
and on top of that a lot of the ins and
outs of building machine learning models
which to this very day is as creative a
process as as a scientific process a lot
of these things will be changing in the
coming years I'll also kind of just flag
the idea of our machine learning as as a
service and a software
more prevalent and you could imagine
that most people in five to ten years
building machine learning models may not
actually be writing writing codes so we
can discuss more that after the fact if
you're if you're interested the other
thing is data science is becoming more
specialized there's there's any Robinson
and something we discussed is the
different types of data scientist you
have and you can you know you can submit
it in a variety of ways but one one word
do it is a type a data scientist which
is an analyst and a traditional
statistician and type B is building
machine learning models you see and you
see this specialization reflected more
more and even in job listings
we'll see data scientists specializing
visualization data scientists building
flashlights machine learning models
these types of things
so that's definitely something to to
keep an eye out for the final point I
want to make about what data scientists
do and I said earlier that you don't
necessarily want the Venn diagram I mean
is that a sense unicorns don't don't
necessarily exist or there aren't many
of them but if you were there data
science consultant you do need to be
able to pick up a lot of things on on
the fly and and and bread and run
different things and I spoke with Vicki
burkas about this and she said that for
consulting it makes sense to be a
generalist you may not need the domain
expertise but you need to be able to
understand what they need and figure out
how to get to the point really
and then offer a solution and if you
have any questions around that
that's Jared actually that's Dave in two
types of data science and what i mean by
that is jacqueline Ellis Doug data
science down into three components is a
lot of people have into business
intelligence into machine learning and
into decision science and we've touched
upon each of these so far but
essentially what she meant is that his
business intelligence being the realm of
descriptive analytics so you take that a
company a tea house get it to the right
people and that can be in dashboards
reports you even do it in emails right
that ancient technology so this is
business intelligence the world of
descriptive analytics and something
tanya casually said is that everyone at
any level should be looking down into
the data the same way that we're
expected to start using email 20 years
ago that means being able to understand
descriptive analytics and how how that
process works and what the output tells
you I gray completely so we have
descriptive analytics then we have
predictive analytics so this can take
the form of putting models continuously
into production for example their
customer lifetime value and and the rest
I mean a lot of examples of predictive
analytics these days which is decision
making or prescriptive and analytics so
we are descriptive predictive and
prescriptive and the analytics which is
essentially taking the insights
discovered from the data science work
and use it to inform decision-making and
so one example that I like to state is
that you know one famous example of
machine learning is predicting with a
customer will churn weather I'll leave
your business or not right make a
decision for you
someone's gonna leave your business what
part of your business model can help you
figure out how to get them to stay how
long before the fact do you try to get
them to stay or if they've already
turned you try to get it get them back
so I suppose the part of this this
example is just noting that the output
of the data science work doesn't
necessarily tell you how to make what
decision to make okay so now we've seen
data science at the high level we've
gone into the nitty-gritty now we talk
about the future of data science I
almost stayed up there thinking about
know what data scientists need to learn
in order to still be valuable in the
coming years so what skills do they data
scientists need to have is a deep
learning is it is that the carnuel
networks the answer to that is no
unfortunately what data scientists need
ever do is ask the right questions and
turn business questions into data
science questions and answers be able to
learn on the fly because tools and
technologies are changing so rapidly
that that's an incredibly important
aspect and then communicating well on
top of that and so these are things that
are advocated from a variety of
different guests coming coming on the
show
then explain complex results to man
technical stakeholders the final point
of course is that we speak to critical
thinking and the more qualitative skills
you can develop their ways of thinking
about the data and modeling the world
and making predictions the better off
you'll be
so now in terms of the future of data
science as I said before very nice and
said to me we have imprecise ethics no
standards of practice and a lack of
consistent vocabulary are these not
enough problems for us today and what I
want to focus on there are many ways to
have this conversation but
came up or on the podcast in season one
was your data ethics or lack thereof and
kind of a nice and burgeoning field of
thinking about data ethics and how to
implement them so we are approaching a
consensus in the community that ethical
standards do need to come from within
data science terms themselves as well as
from regice laterz grassroots movements
and other stakeholders but what can this
look like what type of regulation can
can we think about and emoji milla
github said we need to have an
understanding and ethical understanding
and we need add training you need to
have something I came to a Hippocratic
oath like doctors do and they've a large
conversation happen you know whether an
oath is the most important thing or a
checklist or a code of conduct and I
very much you to check out where the
article avoids and checklists by Michael
Cadiz very nice in India patel kind of
discussing all these options and and the
pros and cons of hmm and this actually
forms part of an e-book as well website
if you search data ethics you you'll
find it they've also been imported into
an e-book which is free on working day
if you have a Kindle out of work for
Amazon so that's fine well they're
definitely coming to New York City
and so one aspect they make clear in
this place is that you know they do some
things checklists may may be more
effective in some ways in terms of just
having basic data science and data data
practice hygiene they give the nice
example that it isn't part of the
Hippocratic oath to wash your hands and
put on gloves before performing
surgeries or doctor that's part of your
internal checklist you know you know
that you do these things and we'll see
kind of examples that might be relevant
to the to the data science space of what
type of things we could include in a
checklist also I've mentioned driven
data while the co-founders which the
podcast they put together a command line
to a good day on that allows you to
easily add an ethics checklist to any
any data science project kind of spoke
to at the start so some interpretable
models as opposed to our bakbox models
and what that means is that you can say
to a stakeholder why the model actually
says what it does so if you look for a
bank in your model doesn't give someone
alone you can actually say to them hey
this is why these are these are the
factors I played it played an important
role and this is why this happens I
think one of the most prevalent almost
talked about examples in recent history
is this recidivism risk score so
ProPublica did a huge X
expose of a model
my compass that will give someone
someone on parole a recidivism restore
so how likely they are to reoffended
released and the operative this motor
was was used in order to infer all
parole hearings and that's exactly what
I wrote here and this feeling you might
not quite tell but what actually
happened was is that it was demonstrated
that our model was biased against black
people and that was that was bias
against particular demographics and
including that one I discussed in great
detail in care news book weapons of mass
destruction which I urge you all all to
read it's about a tomato's out there
that hidden secret non-transparent and
also operating at scale let's really
make the point that one of these biases
already existed in society partners how
non transparent they are now and how I
can operate at scale so that's that's
the conversation we really need to need
to have so she's in the last episode of
the podcast and I said to our like your
definition of data science centers of
data savvy quantitative reminded coding
Richard problem-solver I really do like
that definition of data science and she
said that's not my definition anymore I
said would please tell me a definition
and she said my new definition is that
data science doesn't just predict the
future it causes the future and
essentially what she what she means by
that which i think and think is obvious
is that we have these algorithms in
production that are affecting lives on a
daily basis whether it be you know the
recommendation engines in our pockets
predictive policing
to give loans or judges to to give gift
or not and so it's been with Kathy about
essentially processes that can be put in
place to hold data scientists and
organizations accountable one example
that she's working on she she doesn't
work in data science anymore she has a
letter writing much years has an
algorithmic ordering company which one
built in they can you know they which
was including a sensitivity analysis
which essentially means checking that if
you perturb the inputs a bit weather has
a drastic effect on the output seven
models in weapons of mass destruction
are incredibly sensitive to their inputs
which is is very bad so that's what
she's doing now and she's thinking about
something along with some other
qualities quote in ethical matrix
whether those are the stakeholders and
the columns of a concerns right so this
is an example from looks like Excel this
model when you see you know the
stakeholders are the core black
defendants white defendants the public
Northpoint
I thought that the motors cool encompass
north pointers who made it and then we
say efficiency fairness is concerns
false positive false negatives
transparency maybe a through the data
quality so having this framework for
thinking about development and I think
could be part of a checklist right you
could imagine that on your checklist
before you put them all interaction is
consider all stakeholders or at least
have an
when all the stakeholders are and how
how this affects over them so that could
be an equivalent of washing your hands
for doctor before performing surgery
okay I can't have any conversation about
ethics in data science without thinking
about the plight of open source software
development and I have gone blind John
on the podcast and something says
collator project Jupiter among other
things and he made clear that we're
entering any other large complex
organizations need to scale interactive
computing to the whole organization in a
matter that's collaborative secure and
human centered and I don't you listen to
the episode with Brian because we
actually go through each of these terms
and and this from interactive computing
to a collaborative security and Center
and discuss kind of things about this
this this statement in terms of the
different terms used but essentially
what we're saying is as Brian as a
physicist we call it a phase transition
from a world in which it's a lot of
individual users using open-source
software in order to build to a world in
which we have large organizations
adopting all the open-source software we
need to figure out a way maybe a variety
of different models that work in
parallel how this can can work i do you
think an old friend who's a data
scientist at Novartis now this is a
pretty straightforwardly if you're using
the open source stack then you're
benefiting from others work
to you I'd say it makes perfect sense to
give back of course that doesn't remove
us from the situation of the tragedy of
the Commons whereby we have a public
space and no one feels feels responsible
for it
I also urge you to check out my
interview with Bruce McKinney about this
type of stuff as well and I think when
discussing all of these things once
again it's easy to forget how employment
communities communities are and I think
perhaps that something open-source can
do as well is figure out how to make
their community of contributors as
opposed to having it as a service
economy thinking about how their
community of contributors can go in and
scale as well and get contributors
answering fixing the right issues as
opposed to creating more issues and I
think you know this may be a jobs
conference or a great example of how to
make people feel at home in the data
science community and I just wanted to
kind of give a vision for more problems
essentially so something that I don't
know who coined this term the guarding
Garden of forking assumptions I don't
think it was me it sounds like something
I'd probably say after a few beers but
so [ __ ] for Nia who ones online
experimentation of booking calm he's
responsible for 2,000 people running
online experiments on a daily basis he
builds the infrastructure those are the
products with his team and educates
everyone around around the
infrastructure he said to me that one
assumption people make a lot is that
data is objective okay
and we discussed APOBEC with many
analysts one data set okay
and what these researchers did they gave
25 teams the same data set three five
teams of experts the same data set and
the data set was yellow cards by a
phrase in in soccer okay
and the question posed was am I gotta
get this right yeah is there any arm so
yeah they were also given the rights of
the person was given to and the question
was was there any racism that's the
closest thing that springs to mind
though was it was it racially charged
the distribution of cards yellow cards
in any way and what happened was at
least 25 times seventy percent said yes
and thirty percent said no okay with the
same data set right different analyst
teams were given access to everyone
else's results and they over with more
certain of their own results after the
fact okay different things happening
here but one thing that happens is when
you do an analysis you start making
assumptions everywhere from ABI like
eighty eighty of models in mind right
even if it's subconscious and then you
go down this path where you're making
all these incredible and then quite
larger assumptions and then essentially
you're probably so this makes the
Cassie's point out originally you may be
a on the whole data set and then only
have a holdout set under some later date
right and if you've done that already
you've used your entire data set
including your holdout set for
inspiration so there may be some sort of
confirmation bias happening further and
further down the track and to find out a
bit more clearly the point that first
impressions last from you look at data
and she only as humans did for parents
when we perform analyses were also prone
to confirmation bias the same data is
often used to inspiration and validation
and as Cassie said split word and and
before even looking at it just hold
something out and then you can you can
check it out later
the other thing is that she was used
confidence and precision as proxy for
accuracy as well and this when combined
with our confirmation bias can be very
dangerous in analyses the industry also
lacks consistent workflow or they also
point you in this is another driven data
project called cookie cutter data
science was a template for data science
projects which is which is quite cool
and thinking about any of these things
essentially know otherwise the state of
the industry is similar to medicine
before we had randomized control trials
it is really the Wild West of data
science today and a skipper SIBO
recently gave a talk this is science in
data sensing you get this token and you
can see that online that's about what he
calls the current and coming credibility
crisis in data science and that's
something I'll be talking to skipper
about in season 2 I won't talk about the
future of data science and the fact that
we don't even know where this is going
necessarily and so hello license said we
may even have in 10 years she wouldn't
be surprised if the title goes the way
the webmaster personally really care
whether the title data scientist exists
in in 10 years
is what the slope of enlightenment will
actually look like when we reach it okay
and the CEO better camp rather an HP
article that very few companies expect
only professional writers to know how to
ride so why are are in the professional
data scientists to understand and
analyze data at least at a basic level
okay Dave Levinson also said on the
podcast data literacy is not an
either/or it's a continuum and he thinks
that the deeper everyone gets into it
the healthier the entire community can
be
kind of slightly different points of
view on the same thing as I said don't
care the data scientists exist in ten
years what do care is if we have better
literacy skills and analytical skills
spread through organizations and society
that's somebody we are preparing and
doing data can bear a lot of incredible
people indifference to doing this type
of work but I think that's one of the
most most important important things and
for David Ledbetter Richard I do i do
urge you to wherever you work and travel
is still so some of these basic basic on
ideas and the scales in colleagues thank
you all with a few minutes for questions
so if I see any hands I will hand over
to Mike I see you first cause he's
closer than New York towards thank you
thank you so much sugar for this
brilliant overview and summary of the
field you talked a lot about the the
ethics and ethical checklists one thing
that I sometimes wonder about when this
discussion comes up is and these
decisions already being made in a very
biased way and isn't there an
opportunity in making them
algorithmically in that it allows us to
take out the bias
some way there are several ways to
navigate this the first is a lot of
these algorithms are proprietary and
existing organizations that none of us
have any any idea about so where that
possible the organization could
definitely may be within their control
to do that not ours as a society at the
moment where there are some some
regulations for example in health and
medicine the other answer is that
incentives aren't quite right for
companies to even you know when there's
pushback and when people get hard and
when people stop using the product
that's when that's what that's when it
really starts the third answer is that
in some cases I think maybe the answer
is yes but think about like Facebook's
use integrity algorithm like I'm sure
that they're very smart creative people
ethical people they're trying to figure
this out but it's it's a base right like
I wouldn't even know how to how to start
working with something something like
that or a moving bias from that when you
have you know whatever is happening
democracy being hacked I hope that helps
course if the graph that you showed us
about where we are in data science where
exactly do you feel we are at and do you
think it's cyclical or once we reach a
plateau will we stay there yeah if that
is correct we're definitely before the
peak of inflated expectations because
there's been no chocolate
disillusionment yet I don't think I
haven't seen anyone you know really
strongly question particularly on mass
like now people are coming inside wow
yeah I need money
data science can somebody said to me can
you help
[Music]
slide that you have and skills data
scientists seems to have you know thinks
about turning business questions into
data science data questions and things
like that my colleague and I have been
teaching the basic step on the one type
course and that's what we were telling
our scientist that this is what you need
to do to solve problems using statistics
so my question is how do you distinguish
Stata scientists from astonishing there
is yeah I think I suppose there's a
there's another Venn diagram of data
science and statistics where the
intersection is nearly as large or can
be nearly as large as both of them I do
think data Sciences using statistics and
then having to deal with like
heterogeneous data of like all these
different forms structured unstructured
may be dealing with natural language
processing turning that into you know
vectors or whatever and statisticians
can do that but I do think of data
science as being probably bigger in that
sense if that if that makes sense
I don't know people who have really
disagreed with me on that on on the
podcast actually so I could Betancourt
in particular yeah
piece one not only people there we go
definitely I thought how that weakened
told us that a data scientist is a
statistician with a bowtie yes that's
true
and lives in Brooklyn hey what else last
chance the bar humans come with the ball
right then he was asking a lot more
questions over beer if there are no
other questions I'm calling it alright
thank you very much do you go oh
everyone
there's pizza left is like two pies we
want to get it we usually get one pie
left over eight of you need eh take a
slice we're going to bar toad hall at 50